Yle Areena.
Ja harjataan tuhkatkin pesästä niiltä, joilla ei enää mitää ole, mitä ihmusia on saattanut sielt uunii jäädä edellisestä harjauksesta. Että terveisiä vaan.
Vai tuhkatkin pesästä. Tällaisilla terveisillä aloitettiin tämä kansanradiovuosi. Kiitos ensimmäiselle soittajalle.
Vuoden vaihtumista huolimatta, toivotaan nytkin tutusti, eli tervetuloa mukaan ja matkaan.
Puhetta esimerkiksi nuoruudesta, ruuasta ja uudesta vuodesta.
Tellä kertaa oppaana ajatusten myrskyssä toimii Koiviston Lauri.
Yksi kansalainen linjaa, joulun kestävän kolme päivää. Toinen taas sanoo Suomen kansan alistuneen diktatuuriin.
Ja todetaanpa myös, että vanhuksille pitäis laittaa piikki perseeseen.
Ja nyt matkaamme metsään.
Päädetään metsään sen takia, että voida olla rauhassa.
Ni minkä takia ihmiset tulee vastalla vastaa ja morjeste?
Ei, tänne oo tultu morjestelee.
Kysy vaan, minkä takia? Kiitos.
Metsässä käymisen jälkeen on paikallaan hirvi peijaiset, niihin liittyvää puhetta pian.
Ennen sitä kerron, että meille kansanradioon voi laittaa WhatsApp-viestejä, sekä äskeisenlaisia ääniviestejä, että myös tekstimuotoisia kommentteja.
Kansanradion WhatsApp-numero on 044 551 54 64.
No, tervet, tästä tuli mieleen vaan tää syksyn, influenssa ja lunsan leviäminen, että nämä hirvit veijäiset, mitä nyt eri poja Suomeen on ollut, ja nyt kun on nämä joululaulut ja sitten kaikki muut, pikkujoulut ja muut, niin ei oo ihmin, jos lunsa leviää oikein tosi makeisti.
Joo, hyvää päivää, siis epäilätkö jotenkin hirvi peijaisia nyt erityisesti tällaisiksi lunsa lähteys?
No, niistä leviää hyvin herkästi, ni sää päs etukättelijä varottaa, että semmoisi tilaisuuksii ei kannata tulla, jos on lunsa päällä.
Miksi juuri hirvi peijaiset on tällainen?
No, siellä on kuitenkin semmoista porukkaa, jotka mielellään käyttää vettä väkevämpiä, jos ei oo muistakin porukossa varmaan, pikkujoulut ja muistani.
Se saa pitkä aikaisen taipise, voi kestää kolme, neljä viikkoja, tai käyvä vielä pahemminkin siinä.
Nyt pahimpia juttuja, mitä voi olla, se on alakannut tänä syksynä aikaisin, nämä flunsaat.
Oletko itsekään nyt hirvi peijaisessa?
No, kyllä, minä kävin tänä syksynä, saan oikein kunnoo flunsa, joka on kestannut kolmisen viikkoja.
Joo, ja se tuli just nimenomaan sieltä.
Todennäkösi sieltä, pari vuorokatta myöhemmin, se alakoilla erittää voimakkana.
Lääkiläikitystä on ollut kyllä aika runsaasti, mutta ei se vaan minä antaa periksi.
Nun luonnolaikitystä on apteikiläikityksia, lääkärin määräyksia ja niiden.
Kerroitko lääkärille, että hirvi peijaisesta tuli tähän pois?
Oh, kyllä, mä kerroin, kyllä, mä kerroin sen.
Kahalekin eli lääkärille.
No, kyllähän et sit taljuvaa, mikä on riski olemassa, kun viereen tullaan istumaan lähelle, katolestaan, kun tarttuu tautoni.
Siin oksa pois. Se on hyvin tehokas tarttumaan.
Mitä lääkäri sanoi, kun kerroiti, että hirvi peijaisesta tuli funsa?
No, kyllähän, vähän ihmettilittääkö se, mitä sääntöjä ole.
Silloin, kun oli tämä korona, niin silloinhan tuli eräänkin samaista peijaisista, jossa oli sellainen viisikymmentä, sata, sata kunta henkeä, niin melkeän kaikki sai koronan.
Mitä Suomessa oli sellainen paikka, missä oli tuta?
Nytä oli ympäri Suomea samanlaisia, varmasti, että kun funsa tuli ja asten, tämä korona oli niin kova, niin koko porukka sai.
Sitten Kuopio matkalla linja-autokylse saa toinen porukka, melkeän kaikki tarttuu samassa linja-autossa, niin sai korona.
Tähän loppuu vielä, niin pitäisikö mielestä hirvi peijaiset kieltää, vaikka lailla?
No, ainakin sillä tavalla kieltä, jos kerrannutaan jollaankin lunsani, jos tulee mukaa, niin ei muuta kuin 500 euro sakku.
No nii.
Kiitoksia tästä ehdotuksesta, ja oikein hyvää sunnuntaijatkoa.
Siinä oli puhetta pikkujouluista. Seuraavissa puheluissa käsitellään monesta näkökulmasta joulua.
Täällä, sirkka, mä olen samaa mieltä viime kertaisen soittajan kanssa. Sinä olet käsin kymppinen, minä olin kymmenen vuotta nuorempi, yksin vietän joulun, en tiedä tuleeko lapset tai eksimies, olisi mukava, kiitos.
Tuo muu täällä. Suomessa on ja maailmalla kätevaartamaan.Ko on kristillinen juhla, ni vihollinen tuo siihen sivulle aina toisen juhla.
Joulujuhla on Kristuksen syntymäjuhla, ni siellä on, näitä, pukki tulee sinne, ja sitä ihannoijaan. Coca-Cola rikalla ajetaan, ja, mutta sitten Jeesus lapsi unolet, te on pääsijäine.
No, sinne on tullut sitten noidat, ja tipuut, ja kaikki nämä, ja, sitä syötetään niin paljon, että tavallinen kansa ei näe, eikä kuule, mikä on.
Kaisessanoma. Se on kristikunnan tärkein sanoma.Sitten syksyllä on näitä Halloweenia, ja näkee niistä Halloweenista, että pääkalloja, sitten niitä naamareita.
Se on aivan vihollisesta kaikki tämmöne.
No hei, hei, kiva, että joulua on pian ohi. Meinaan olen niin lopeen kyllästynyt tähän iän ikuiseen jankutukseen, että onko ny valkeaa joulua, voi voi, jos ei ny oo valkeaa joulua.
Ai, ai, et on ny pilalla, jos on mutta jouluja, mutta maa, ja. Ihan tämmöstä amerikkalaisesta hapatusta. Et ennystää ihmettelee, et amerikkalaiset tykkää Suomesta, sotilaalisestakin mielestä, ku tää nyt näin amerikkalaisia ollaan. Et hyvä tosiaan, et joulua piaa ohi, ni pääsee taas tostaki jankutuksesta, ainakin vuodeks eteenpäin. Moi.
Pauli tältä Savosta, Kuopiosta, terve, kansanradiola. Tanaan 27. päivän joulukuta, ni joku tolutti hyvää joulunjatkoa.
Eihän, herranjumala, se 87. päivää on joulukuta, mikään joulu. Että jouluaartoe, jouluaartoe se loppuu tapaanin päe. Mutta jotkotat hirveetä jo, taas, taas, joka päivä jo. Kyllä mun mielestä kolme päivää riittää. Jouluaatto, joulupäivää, tapaanin päe. Kiitos kansanradion kuuntelee, tää on hyvää alkavaa uutta muutta, 26. Hei, hei.
Hei, hei, hei, ja kiitos Paulille. No, meillä kansanradiossa ainakin vielä jatketaan jouluajatuksin hetken aikaa. Monien mielestään joulun aika kestää loppiaiseen saakka, ja toisten mielestä ihan nuutin päivään asti.
Ennen puheluita WhatsApp-viesti, joka käsittelee niin sanottua neljättä joulupäivää, viestissä lukee näin:
Viattomien lastenpäivää voitaisiin viettää kaikkien lasten muistopäivänä, jotka Putin on tappanut päiväkotea lastensairaloita pommittamalla.
Näin kirjoitti nimerkki Pappa, WhatsApp-sovelluksen kautta tulleessa viestissään.
Juha Tamperilta tässä vaan, ajattelin iloista porukkaa oma tekemällä joulurunolla. Se kuuluu näin:
Mutta ei ole huolen häivää, sillä onhan jo tapanin päivää. Oikein mukavaa joulun aikaa kaikille, voivottaa Juha Tampereelta.
Tulee niin pahaa mieli tästä joulukonsertista kansalle, korkealta ja kovaa.
Siis kerta kaikkiaan, katääkö tämä nyt on, ettei meillä ole taiteilijoita, jotka eivät kiinnitä, siihen huomioitat, kuinka korkealle ja kovaa mennään. Kiitoksia.
No joo, minun nimeni on Kinnunen Pekka, Jyvästylästä ja semmoinen asia.
Joulurauhan julistus julistettiin jouluaattona Turussa, kaupunkilaisille, toistan, kaupunkilaisille.
Mutta mihin unohtui maaseudulla asuvat ihmiset? Kiitoksia.
Niin Pekka, Turun joulurauhan julistuksen teksti on sen verran vanha, että silloin sitä ei ollenkaan radioitu eikä televisioitu.
Näin ollen siitä syystä se teksti on osoittu vain kaupunkilaisille, eli turkulaisille, eikä kaikille suomalaisille.
Luin pari viikkoa sitten ylen uutista jutun, että vanha julistusteksti on haluttu säilyttää, vaikka nykyisin se läheltään myös Turun ulkopuolellekin.
Seuraavassa puhelussakin mainitaan joulu, mutta enemmän ollaan, kuitenkin yleisimmin, ulkomaan asioissa.
Kukkoille, Itä-Suomesta, soitteille, on kuunnellu, miten tuota jouluaikaan tämä Putini on ampelias ja hyvä syväminen ihminen.
Hän on muistama ukrainoa lukemattomille pommiloille, ja niille melvitihäkkylille, ja mitähän nyt on kuitenni.
Nen se antaa, Putini antaa ihan hyvästä syväminen nämä kaikki.
Semmosi ihmisiä täällä ei tarvittais enempiä, ei muuta heippa.
Täällä on kuuntelija, joka sanoo mielipiteensä, Venäjällä on rahaa, ja Euroopan pankkissaki kolmesataa miljardia euroa.
Euroopalla ei ole rahaa, eikä Ukrainalla ole rahaa.
Miettikäs pikkuisen, mikä siitä tulee. Raha ei kasva puissa. Nyt pitää ottaa kyllä järki kätee. Jät, jät, pitos.
Moi, tuli tässä mieleen, että jos tämä Ukrainan sota nyt sitten loppuu lähiaikoina, niin sitten siellä on töitä, valtava, uudelleenrakennus.
Ja, nyt ku Suomi on pumpannu sinne aineski kolme miljardia veromaksajia rahoja, ja sehän on Ukraina suuri vilja aitta, niin, ja jos se käynnistyy, se iso, maailman suurimpi kuuluva ydinvoimala, niin, jos Suomessa on kato viljasta, me voidaan sieltä saada edullisesti ostaa viljaa ja sähköä, pulan aikana saadaan sieltä sähköä.
Sielähän on myöskin paljon erilaisia mineraaleja, mitä Suomiski voidaan käyttää.
Et, nyt sitten, tämä kannattaa huomioida, ens vuonna ehkäpä, kaupan käynnissä, koska Suomi on suorastaan lapioinut sinne rahaa, ainakin kolme miljardia.
Elikkä, meidän täytyy vähän saada niitä rahoja sieltä takasipäi, että, nää kaks tomppelii orpoja purra nyt vaan niinku yrittää tätä maata, vanna niinku syäksykierteeseen, järkyttävää.
Kohta ollaan tuolla torppariajassa, köyhälistöt ja kerjäläiset liikkuu kohta kadulla. Toivottavasti ei. Huh, huh, järkyttävä kaksekko, voi voi.
Nyt on aika palata kotimaahan ja siirtyä politiikan ajatusten pariin. Aloitetaan teema Postikortilla.
Hyvä kansanradio. Jotkut kansanedustajat ovat alkaneet kiillottaa Suomikuvaa oikein hartiavoimin.
Kaksi heistä ja yksi Meppi ovat revitelleet kasvojaan julkisuudessa irvokkaan rasistisesti, ja yksi on ammuskellut humalapäissään kadulla.
Kalkeelliset käytöstä ovat, mutta mitä vielä? Eihän se niin ole.
Ajatelkaapa, että tällaisilla aivoilla tehdään valtakunnan politiikkaa.
Tällä tavoin kirjoitti Postikortisnyymerkki käyttäytymisen alkeiskurssi pakolliseksi eduskuntaan.
Meille kansanradioon voi laittää kortteja ja muuta perinteistä postiasoitteeseen.
Kansanradio PL 79 00 00 24 Yleisradio.
Terve, Minna täällä.
Terve, Minna.
Ja Kekkonen.
No nii.
Ko kaikki huutaa Kekkosta sykkyä apua.
Tää on kauhe?
Joo, aika jännä tilanne. Mut tiedätkö, mikä siinä oiks?
Mun mielestä, tämä vaihtoehto, miksi huudetaan.
Ny kerra.
Sen takii, et meillä on ni hemmetin paskahallitus.
Mikä tahansa kelpais, jopa Kekkonen.
Niin, näin epäilet, nyt ette.
Joo, koska, mä en tiedä, tää varmaan surkein hallitus, mikä on tehny surkeita.
Lain muutoksia.
Mikä tekee tästä hallituksesta nii surkeaan mielehtisi?
No nimenomasti yks asia on, tää lain valmistelut.
Ilman selvityksiä otetaan perustoimeentulotuet.
Sitten laitettiin mukamas 65-vuotiaille, ja siitä yli, niin kelan nämä lääkäripalvelut,
joissa ei oo edes seurantaa, mihin niitä käytetään.
Elikkä, tota, ni mä epäilen kylät.
Ni, tehään tämmösiä kaikkiä älyttömyyksiä, ja hintalappua ei mietitä, ja aina pitäis tehdä selvitysvaikutuksista.
Eihän täällut tehti mitään.
Et, tämähän koko ajan kävelee kaikki niiku hallituksen yli, ja tänne skipataan, ilman niiku, selvityksiä, työllisyysarvioista, esimerkiks otetaan datakeskukset, ja se on muuta.
Niin, tehään tämmösiä äkkivääriä juttuja, ja äkkiä vaan läpi, aivan uskomatonta.
Ni, mä oon ikinä tämäs nähnyt.
Joo, eli hallitus on mielestäni surkea, mutta olisiko Kekkonen nyt hyvä vaihtoehto?
Ei, ei Kekkonen pärjäis.
Ai, joo.
Ei se pärjäis, ei, ajatellaan nyt, se lovastas kuitenki, Putin ja Trumpini.
Kyl mä vähän epäilen, miten Kekkonen pystis taas menemään niiku pikselemään.
Ai, niin, että Kekkonen ei oo heitä kovempi, meinaatko näe?
Kyl mä, kyl mä vähän meinaan, että ei, ei, ei, ei oikein varmaanko.
Se on vähän eri asia, semmonen neuvostolyttomalli.
Tota, aijai, paha paikka tulis.
Kiitos, Minna, näistä ajatuksista, ja hyvää sanota jatkoa.
Hyvä, kiitos, moi.
Perussuomalaisten rasismista järki hoi, äly, älä, jätä.
Täällä Sirpa Anneli ihmettelee, että mikäli perussuomalaisten kansanedustajat saavat vain pelkän vakavan huomautuksen, Suomen maineen ja itsensä häpäisemisestä.
Eli, mikä rangaistus se semmoinen on verrattuna Miss Suomea kohtaan, joka menetti koko tittelinsä ja arvonimensä Miss Suomeksi, joka annettiin perintöprinsessalle.
Tällöin Miss Suomi menetti mahdollisuutensa moniin työpaikkoihin jatkossa Miss Suomena.
Samalla tavoin täytyisi kohdella myös kansanedustajia ja poistaa myös heidänkin arvonimensä, ja ottaa varalle olijat tilalle.
Siinä olisi vasta oikea todellinen esimerkki tasa-arvosta Suomessa.
Löytyykö oikeus samaan tasa-arvoon Suomessamme, ja vielä vastaavassa tilanteessa, kyselee kansalainen Sirpa A.
Toivotaan parasta, kiitos.
Vaalit Suomen, ku tämmöistä silmien vääntelyjä, muita kääntelyjä, joissa hallitusohjelmissa pyörii.
Ei muuta, kun uudet kansanedustajat vaalit, ja sitten uudet kansanedustajat esille.
Terveis eläkeläinen.
Suomen kansa on näköjä aalistettu jo diktatuuri, kun ei oo kaksuatta, eikä vielä oo hallitus menny, nuri kukana, jostella protestoida yhtään mitään.
Täällä ei terveisi eläkeläise, kiitti, heitti.
Listu täällä, runonpätkä.
Persut Suomen hustuja, keittävät kaurahuttua, köyhällä tyhjä mahaa, ei ruokarahaa, ihmisen peräpää ei pauku, koira ei perään hauku.
Ette, sellainen, terkkuja, kansanradiolle, heippa.
Täällä oo 90-vuotias mummo, minulla oo asiaa Riikka Purrolle.
Nyt, kun olet ajamassa tätä Suomea 1800-luvulle vanhusten ja vammaisten hoidossa, minä neuvon, anna meille piikkiperseeseen,
Niin eduskunta saa joulurahansa ja vuoden vaihteessa palkankorotuksen.
Puomi on ollut viimesodasta nousukiidossa, vaikka on ollut huonoja aikoja.
Tämä hallitus ottaa köyhiltä ja antaa rikkaille, kiitos.
Tämän mummon puhelun jälkeen keskiöön pääsevät lapset ja nuoret.
Ennen puheluita, vielä yksi sähköposti, lääkkeistä. Siinä lukee näin.
Kun henkilökohtainen lääkkeiden maksukatto täyttyy vuoden vaihteessa, saa kuluttaja sen jälkeen lääkkeensä lähes ilmaiseksi.
Eivät lääkkeet ilmaisia ole, kuka ne maksaa? Kela ja veronmaksaja, viime kädessä koko arvostaan.
Veronmaksaja ei ole velvollinen kustantamaan toisen ihmisen lääkkeitä ja tukemaan hänen terveyttään ja hyvinvointiaan.
Verokertymät kuuluu käyttää yhteisten asioiden kustannuksiin, ei sattuman varaisesti yksittäisten ihmisten tarpeisiin.
Tällaiset maksut tai huojennukset ovat verovarojen väärinkäyttöä.
Näihin sanoihin päätti sähköpostisen niumerkki MLK.
Kansaradion sähköpostiosoite on kansan.radio@yle.fi.
Minä oon semmonen yhdeksäkympinen mommu ja minä kuuntelee noita uutisia.
Kauhistelee sitä, että miksei on isät ja äiti, pikku pojat kulkee puukkoja kastuloja.
Mikä niitä puuttuu? Niitä puuttuu kotirakkaus ja isä ja äiti.
Tämä meni vain tietokonekansaksi, lapset jää jalakkoihin tuonne.
Tietokoneita ja nettie jalakkoihin.
Net poloset puukonkastulo kulkee ja toisia kaverita pistelee piirtää.
Voisko aika ottaa semmonen asia ja päättää, että nyt hoidattaa lapsia eikä niitä tietokoneita?
Volkaa ihmiset järkeviä ja hoitakaa lapsentaa.
No tässä, 70-luotias vaan hapatuin.
Taas viime perjantaina kuuntelin, kuinka nuorisoa taas haukuttiin oikein.
Äänestä päätelin tällaisia niinku minäki, kuusseittämänkympisiä, että, kuika tuota, nuoriso ahdistelee tyttöjä ja juo kaliaa ja meuhkaavat joka puolella ja hajelevat mopoilla.
Silloin, ku me oltiin nuoria, niin ei silloin ollut mopoja. Kiitos.
Heikko kokkonen, hyvää päivää, kuulin turpin, että.
Hannottais tämä some kieltää, nuorilas on ihan oikein, se pitää kieltää, myös tällä Suomessa, koska tuota, ja sitten toinen asia on myös nämä energiajuomat.
Nämä juovat, nämä nuoret, itsensä sairaksineella, energiajuomalella, hampaa, suusta, tuota, noin, ja.
Se ei ole mitään järkiä, että ne kiskovat tuota litkua menemään, ja tämä someni, heillä tuolla, heidän aika mennei tähän.
Hiproksista, he, Johnny, joota, vaan tuota, noin.
Sitä pitää ehdottomasti kieltää, että rajoittaa vähintään jollakin tavalla.
Tämä nuorisoa vaikaa voimaan paremmin, vaikaa voimaan paremmin, tähän saakka suurin osa ei voi hyvin.
Tämmöset oli terveiset. Kiitoksia, hei.
Sleepers laulaa, että syö lanttuva. Se tuli mieleeni seuraavasta puhelusta, vuorossa siis ruokateemaisia ajatuksia.
Liisa terve, ihme tyttää tää kasvien jalostustyö.
Sit nyt on lanttu niin mieto, se ei tuoksu lantulle, se ei maistu lantulle.
Ainoastaan ulkonäöstä ja pussiin päältä lukiestaan, niin huomaa, et, jaa, tää on lanttua.
Minkä takia nii lanttuki on pitänyt tämmoseks tehdä?
Et, et, pitääks sitä nyt vaan syödä sit sen takia, et siitä saa kuitua vai?
Ei se, maku nyt oo yhtään tärkeä.
Ihmettelä, moi.
Ei, kansanruo, olisikohan ollut niin, että kaksituhatta ihmistä Suomessa olisi jouluyönä mennyt nälkäsenä nukkumaan,
jos Hurstin ja hänen tiimiänsä hyvän tekeväisyysjärjestö ei olisi ollut?
Niin, olikohan näin? Pysyy, kansalainen.
No, iletältä, puistolasta, hei. Minulla on tämmönen ehdotus, mä oon tämmönen puolikokki,
että, jos on vähän varaisia, voisin kertoa tämmösen ohjeen,
mites sais tota hemmetihyviä voileipiä tehtyy, halvalla, kuudelle hengelle.
Tuotteen hinnaks tulisi, noin seitsemä euroa koko.
Jutska, että siinä ois kuudelle hengelle aika hyvä, satsi.
Tää lähtis näennettää.
Noin kaksataa viiskymmentä grammaa.
Lohta, palana.
Yksi, sipuli.
Noin, kourallinen, tilliä.
Merisuolaa.
Yksi, teelusikallinen.
Tos on tehosekoitin.
Niin, ok.
Soseeksi.
Niin, sitten se on valmis.
Laita paahtoleivän, tai ruislievän päälle, plus sitruunaviipale.
Ja, jos on niin, majoneesia.
Riittää noin kuudelle hengelle, moi.
Hei vaan, täällä yksi mummeli.
Olen työstymisen asti kuunnellut rariosta, kuinka kaikkia hienoja ruokia on.
Voletteko ajatelleet myös, että niitä ihmisiä on paljon, joilla ei ole tämmöisiä herkkuja pöyrässä?
Voisitte vähän ajatella, että ei sitä joka tuhtista tulisi, sitä ruulanlaittoa ja ruulanlaittoa.
Olisi, sitä muutakin tekemistä varmasti olluna.
Tämä, tää, sitten.
Terveisiä kaikilla kansanarjoilla, hei.
Hei, sinne.
Äskeinen soittaja mainitsi radion.
Seuraavat kannanotot vievät meidät sähköisten joukkotiedotusvälineiden maailmaan.
Hei, tää, Helena, Turusta.
Mä oisin ihmetellyt semmoista asiaa, kun televisiosta ei tule yhtään englannikielisiä uutisia.
Silloin, kun mä joskus tulin Australiasta pois, niin täällä oli, ykköselta tuli nii kolmelta iltapäivällä nii semmoista kolmen minuutin englannikieliset uutiset.
Mut, sitten ne lopetettiin, kuulemma, Pustarusseista.
Kuitenkin nii, peneläiset uutiset on aivan, aivan parati paikalla tuolla iltapäivällä, nii, nii, eikä yhtään englannikielisiä uutisia.
Ihmittelemään.
Nimimerkillä Jussi tätä pohjospohjampalta soitteloa.
Ajatteli sen takia soittaa kansanradioon, ku tuoh on tullu uusi nainen lukemaa noitani uutisia, Petra Nykäne.
On todella semmoinen osaava, joka tekee, kaikki niinko kuuluu, on nii hyvän näköne, ja muutenki, että toivon tälle naiselle hyvää menestystä, ja siinä on yle saanut kyllä todella hyvää uutisankkurit.
Ei muuta ko kaikkia hyvää menestystä hänelle, ja hellureja hellätunteet.
No hei, täällä on yksi mamma, joka soittelee tämmöisestä asiasta, joka harmittaa niin televisiota katsellessani, kun tulee ihania luontodokumentteja, luontoelokuvia, ja jotain tämmöisiä vastaavia.
Hirveä musiikkipilaa koko ohjelman, eikö voisi esittää ilman mitään musiikkia, mutta ei voi laittaa musiikkia pois päältä,
vai sitten taas muutenne, tietysti ku luontokuvia.
Tämä musiikki on aivan hirveetä, mitä soitetaan, ja nämä luonto-ohjelmat, ne on nii ihania, ja kalastus, metsästys ja kaikki semmoiset, ni siinä ei tarvii mitään musiikin pauhata.
Kiitos. Toivottavasti saamme muutoksen hyvin kauniseen luontodokumentteihin ynnä muihin, ilman musiikkia. Heippa.
No, minä olen vain tältä, etilä Suomesta oleva nishenkilöä, nimeni on Maire.
Haluaisin tämmöistä asiaista vaan huomaa tätä. Se alkaa kyllä sitä, ku jatkuvasti mainostetaan tätä tulevia ohjelmia, koko ajan sanotaan samaa, tunnin aikanaan vaikka uinko moita kerppää.
Han osaltaan ulkoon jo, koko ajan tulee ne samat asiat, uut asiat, siis oikeat ohjelmat jää niinko kokonaan ihastit varjoon, koska näitä vaan luetellaan tulevia ohjelmia, samaa se on televisiön puolestaki.
Kyllä sen mulla on radio aina auki, televisiö on va iltasi, mut koko ajan sielläkin selitää, mitä on tulossa. Se ohjelma, mikä oikeasti olis silloin menossa, niin seki päättä kiintyy siinä koko ajan. Semmostia terveisiä vaan sinne päättäjille. Heippaa.
Kohta on luvassa uuteen vuoteen liittyviä pohdintoja. Ennen niitaan paikallaan muistuttaa, että kansarion uusi jakso ilmestyy tänäkin vuonna Yle Areenaan joka perjantai, kello 21.
Jos merkkaat sydämen kuvasta, ja tilaat ohjelmasta ilmoitukset kellon kuvasta, niin saat aina ensimmäinen tiedon, kun uusi jakso ilmestyy Yle Areenaan.
Hän täytyi sanoa, että meidän arvostus mausu tasa oron pesistiä kohtaan. Hän antoi henkilökohtaisista varoista 500,000 nuorille, nuorille toimintaa tuki. Myös se, että hän kävi Turulokomossa vähävalaisten joulujuurossa ja naitiesimerkkiä.
Ja toivosen, kun nämä varakkaat ihmiset saa hyvät veron helpotukset ens vuoda, esimerkiksi ministeriikki täytää saada 5000 euroa edelmän käteen ens vuodaen, että sieltä sitten voitais lahjottaa vähävalaisille ja pöydelapsille, että annettais sieltä sitten sellainen summa, ja auttais.
Kun se on sammosta, kun puhutaan, sitko puhutaan hyvätulosten, verokiristyksestä. Sitten mainitaan juu, että me muutetaan ulkomaille, teillä haluaa veroja maksaa, muun muassa on erittäin epäisää maalista.
Ne on täällä koulutettu, ja koulut on maksettu, ja sit ei haluttais kuitenkin osalistu tämän yhteiskunnan kehittämiseen.
Ei muuta, kun hyvää uutta luottaa kansanradion toimitukselle. Toivota taas ihan hyvää kansanradioa, etää nyt tämän vuoden. Toivotaan, että jatkossa menee samaan tyyliin, moi.
Mutta sunnuntai, ilta, yö, akspens kahdeksas päivät, ja maanantai, vasten yö ihmetytti, ja kummastutti. Heräsin unesta noin kahdentoista aikaan, joku ampui laukauksen.
Ajattelin, tais peura, päästä henkestään, koska maantie menee tuosta, läheltä. Oli hetken hiljaista, taisin torkahtaa.
Kunnes alkoi paukua oikein jatkuvasti. Kello oli jo ainakin yksi ja kaksi, kun paukuttelu jatkui.
Sitten pieni tauko oli välillä. Kun olin hetken nukkunut, heräsin uudelleen ja katsoin kelloa, kun paukuttelu jatkui.
Kello oli kymmentä vaille neljä aamuyöstä. Eikö hyvin tapoihin kuulu, että uudenvuoren paukuttelukin lopetetaan jo siinä kahden aikaan yöllä.
Mutta tämä, maanantai, aamuyö, kello kymentä vailla neljä, moniko jaksaa lähteä töihin kuuren seitsemän aikaa, jos se on valvonut naapurissa ammuttavien paukujen tähden koko yön.
Tämä ampuja o, paras lähdön, kai hänellä oli siihen hyvä syy, jokin suuri juhla tai muu.
Mene ja tiedä. No, toivotaan kaikille. Oikein hyvää uutta vuotta. Kiitos.
Kiitos sinulle, ja vielä on luvassa uuteen vuoteen liittyvä Olavin runo.
Nyt kerron kuitenkin kansaradion puhelinnumeron. Se on 08 001 54 64.
Puhelu on soittajalle maksuton, ja muistutuksena, että sunnuntaisin kello 12:30 alkaen, tuossa numerossa vastaa ihmis vastaa ja kolmen tunnin ajan.
Olari soittaa hyvää päivää. Soitan, runoni, kohti uutta vuoden vaihtuessa.
Hei, jokainen suomalainen, ootpa nuori tai vanha, mies tai nainen. Kun vuosi vaihtuu, ja alkaa uus, meille tarjoutuu uusi mahdollisuus.
Nytpä aletaan samaan hiilee puhaltamaan. Maan talous laitetaan kohdalleen. Asiat tärkeys järestykseen.
Yhteistyölle tuo kaikki onnistunee. Kyllä Suomessa viisaalta miehiä riittää. Myös naisia, ne ovan teräviä.
Kenties saamme aikanaan heitä kiittää. Pää pystyyn, ja katse tulevaan. Luja usko, ja luottamus huomiseen. Luja luottamus korkeimpaan. Hyvää uutta vuotta.
Tämän vuoden ensimmäisen jakson lopuksi suuntaamme vielä, ainakin Rovaniemelle.
Enen viimeisiä puheluita, minä toivotan teille kaikkea hyvää, ja nyt erityisesti tätä alkanutta vuotta.
Koiviston lauri kiittää ja kumartaa. Kansan radio, jälleen viikon päästä.
No, hyvä iltapäivä, seniori täällä. Minä nyt soitan, että tuleepa mieleen aikaisemmatki talvet. Rovaniemelentokentällä.
Se ongelma on ollut useampana talvena. Sama virsi, samat jonot, ollut vielä kovemmatkin pakkaset, missä asiakkaat ovat joutuneet odottamaan.
Se on törkeintä Suomelta, että te ette edes majoitusta heille, hanki, ruokaa, lounassetua ja mitään muutakaan, kun joutuvat odottamaan.
Jos olis muualla ulkomailla, niin siellä kaikki järjestetään, ja tulee välittömästi matkatoimistolta viesti, kuponki sinne, kuponki tänne, mene sinne ja hoidetaan.
Tää on sissikamaista palvelua Suomelta, maine menee, turhaa selityksiä on, täytyypä sanoa, että, olenpa, ihan samaa mieltä, että Suomessa ei mikään toimi, kaikki toimii päin peetä.
Joka päivä huonomia huonommin oli asia, mikä tahansa. Nämä selitykset ei mene läpi, ne on kaikki menetettyjä matkustajia, ja sana kulkee suusta suuhun ympäri maailmaa.
Kerran näytetty, mikä maa Suomi on, hyvät illanjatkoa.
Nyt on parahitsi lunta, maa on justiisin valkoona, ei tämän enänpää tarvitkaa olla lunta, ku tuota, se on valkoosna vain maa, ei sitä enänpää tarvitse olla, täältä Pohjanmaata.
Kylä sitä jouluksi tuli sen verran lunta, ku tarvittoa, ei muuta.
Mikä on onnen mitta?Tavar paljous, vaiko henkinen pää oma?